i have a kind of peripheral sense that
i'm disliked by some people but you know
i don't i don't have a television i
don't i don't go on the internet i don't
use social media i'm pretty i'm pretty
insulated from that stuff because
literally you literally don't i know you
don't check twitter but you literally
don't have a television oh no i've never
had it i've never had a tv no
no no i just didn't you know i didn't
grow up like that and my dad worked in
tv when i was a kid and he was
he was pretty pro reading i would say he
was a militant reading person so yeah we
had a lot of enforced reading in our
house and so yeah that's how i grew up
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the host of tucker carlson tonight on
fox news and the author of the new book
the long slide 30 years in american
journalism tucker carlson welcome back
to the reuben report ladies and
gentlemen thanks for having me dave
tucker you are not in your studio you're
not in a suit you appear to be in some
sort of secret bunker area with books
and pictures what's going on over there
i'm in i'm in my barn actually to be
totally honest which is where i work i
live in a rural area in northern new
england and we have an old barn that we
use for
everything basically to store the boats
and
my wife has her peloton and we have our
studio in it and you know bunk beds for
people and so yeah i live in my barn
so you're kind of living the dream that
you always wanted in a way i mean a
couple years ago i've quoted this many
times quoted you actually many times you
walked into my house open the door to my
garage and i don't know if fox news is
going to want me to say the exact thing
you said but you basically said
holy effin [ __ ]
you've done it meaning that i had a
studio at home and i was able to run my
operation you you've kind of expanded
into that world while still maintaining
the mainstream cred
what yeah i mean
i have to say
i've always believed that what matters
is how you live you know what's your
what's your life like what do you do
when you wake up what time do you wake
up who do you wake up with i mean those
are the things that define your life
and so when i saw how you lived i
thought man
this guy is really i mean i know people
who make a ton of money
who don't live anywhere near as well as
you do and i was just so impressed by
that and um of confluence of events
happened and what i'm i mean we actually
live in the town that we've been in our
whole lives so it's not we didn't move
anywhere weird we this is where you know
we had a house here always growing up
but
um
why not just move there and so we did
and it's been wonderful
yeah and you were dealing with some
headaches living in some other places
because you know obviously the media
matters people and all the usual trolls
and everything they were sending people
to your house and right you know going
out i mean literally like going after
your wife and kids and all that i know
it's not fun to talk about that but can
you just talk about it a little bit just
sort of relative to you're just trying
to do what you think is right as a as a
journalist and as a personality and then
how it affects the the life and the
people around you yeah i mean it was
just sad to see it happen i moved to
washington as a kid my dad worked for
the federal government and um on the
cold war and doing pretty honorable
things i would say i think that anyway
and um so i've lived in washington
essentially my whole adult life i mean
since high school
and it's a bipartisan town i mean by
definition both parties are represented
both parties live there and as a result
there's been this permanent truce
effectively for decades where you can
live next to people you disagree with
but you don't talk about it at dinner
parties you can be friends anyway and i
love that environment a lot of my
friends had politics different from mine
and then
in 2016 trump was such a threat they
were so worried not that trump would
actually do anything and he really
didn't as as
as we know
but he said stuff and he said obvious
stuff and they were so terrified that
trump was going to point out some really
obvious things about the way things
actually work that they were completely
threatened by i mean really threatened
by him it was like a foreign power
occupying the city and the hatred the
bitterness
and i just kind of agreed with a lot of
trump's i don't know ideas may be a
little strong but themes
you know like when you run the
government you should always ask
yourself is this helping the people who
live here who voted for me who pay for
all of this whose country it is i really
agree with that i always have so um
that the division in the city between
the overwhelming majority of people who
saw trump as this satanic figure and the
tiny minority of us who are like well
yeah okay trump
whatever it's obvi you know he's got all
these personal faults got it but he's
making really good points
like what is the point of nato for let
me just pick one of a thousand examples
why shouldn't we have a border wall you
know what about all those people who
died of fentanyl like
what's the answer
and all of a sudden it just became
impossible to live there and then
you know i've never lived behind a gate
or anything we live right on the street
in the city all that raised my kids my
four kids there and all of our dogs and
all this stuff and i felt like we were
really part of the city and then
next thing you know people are showing
up at the house and you can sort of see
where this is going you know it's so
threatening
you know where does it end you're going
to end up shooting somebody and i don't
want to do that you know i hate but
that's that's where it's going you know
because just living there was so
provocative to them
having them show up and threaten
violence against my family was so
threatening to me
that it just it wasn't going to end well
and i just thought
and our fourth child went off to
boarding school
and we didn't have any kids at home and
so we're like well wait you know why
don't we just move to where we already
spent the summer so we did
yeah so do you think that the people
that you're talking about there that are
sort of the permanent dc class and the
swamp as trump would call them do you
think it's a conscious decision that
they're always existing to keep
themselves in that power or is it just
that you just get there and then before
you know it you're just in this thing
and and you like what's happening so you
just stay in that thing so that's why he
was the threat to it and i would argue
that in a weird way you now that trump
has stepped away a lot of the hatred
that was just always directed towards
trump is now directed more towards you
because you're carrying the torch for
some of those ideas yeah i mean i'm not
totally aware of that i i have a kind of
peripheral sense that i'm disliked by
some people but you know i don't i don't
have a television i don't i don't go on
the internet i don't use social media
i'm pretty i'm pretty insulated from
that stuff because
literally you literally don't i know you
don't check twitter but you literally
don't have a television
oh no i've never had it i've never had a
tv no
no no i just didn't you know i didn't
grow up like that and my dad worked in
tv when i was a kid and he was
he was pretty pro reading i would say he
was a militant reading person so yeah we
had a lot of enforced reading in our
house and so yeah that's how i grew up
but um
yeah but mostly you know i i have a very
close circle of friends and i have a big
family and i'm really close to my wife
and my producers who i absolutely love
my executive producer i'm really close
to them so i have a lot of people around
me
who will tell me the truth and do
um if they think i'm being a douche or
i'm crossing some line or whatever
they'll just say it i mean they're not a
friend they're not afraid of me at all
so unfortunately um so i
i feel like i've got a pretty good
series of backstops against going
totally crazy
and so and then i really care about
their opinion because these are people i
love and respect
and so my view has always been my whole
life
you know i had a weird childhood which
kind of changed my view on this but
but fundamentally it was you should only
care about the opinions of people who
care about you
and who have you know demonstrated
loyalty and wisdom and an ongoing
relationship why would you ever let
strangers
have control of your emotional state
like that's insane and you know you hear
people say that but i think i'm in the
rare category of people who mean it so i
would never go online and like google
myself why would i do that
no i really i know you mean it
right exactly i i know you mean it
because i think the first time we met in
person i asked you something about the
hate and the twitter mentions and you're
like i don't have twitter like it's you
you know it's tucker carlson on twitter
we're like it's not you know i'm not the
one checking it and tweeting this stuff
and that keeps you kind of insulated and
safe and sane it's yeah and and i have a
huge number of people i talk to every
day i mean i spend my whole life talking
to people mostly by text but hundreds of
people and i try to clear my text every
night it was up until two in the morning
in front of the fire where i live it's
cold um on september 1st and uh with my
dogs you know and i'm up really late
banging out these texts taking notes so
i i i speak to a ton of people and not
just people in my world not just famous
rich people but like a lot of random
people
a waitress that i had in big sur i hope
she's watching this i know she's a fan
of yours
years ago has
i gave her my text for some reason she
and her husband are like such thoughtful
people and she has been texting me ever
since and i swear once a month two
nights ago i used one of her lines on
the air
like at least once a month i'll like run
with the story ideas she sends me so i
have a huge number of people that i
correspond with
but i don't want to open it up to the
mob i mean i because then i can't think
clearly and my whole job is
you know and i don't always pull it off
but i really try to think clearly like
what is going on here you know ascend a
little bit get higher look down
what are the outlines of this and being
involved in this [ __ ] you [ __ ] you too
you know
i don't like noise in my personal life
i like quiet and i don't like noise in
my work or intellectual life you know i
like to i like to think i like nature
you know i like i like hunting and
fishing i like to be outside
i don't want to sit in a room and read
other people's hysteria i don't think
there's any upside to that at all if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about the media
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our media playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out the full episode
playlist they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell